macarthur
criticized truman publicly
said there is no substitute for victory
there wasn't much time after the victory
over
germany and japan for popping champagne
corks and celebrating
uh just as the 50 nations that had
joined in defeating the axis powers were
drafting a charter for the united
nations in san francisco the victorious
alliance between the united states and
the soviet union was falling apart
war alliance between the united states
and britain and the soviet union was
tactical
exclusively there was no other
ideological or sentimental attachment
between the nations and
as
the the war appeared to be won in
europe's spring of 1945 the red army
began
uh
occupying more and more portions of
eastern europe with
the clear intention of establishing a
soviet empire this is exactly what
churchill was worried about in march of
1946 winston churchill gave a speech in
america in which he uttered
a phrase that would live on for a long
time he said that from stetton in the
baltic to trieste in the adriatic an
iron curtain has descended across the
continent so
uh what to do about this expansionist
tendency
short of fighting a war
well what truman arrived at was a
conclusion heavily influenced by the
writings of george cannon an american
diplomat in russia who
believed that soviet expansionism was
actually a result of the insecure
unstable nature of the regime itself
and that
the process of expansion was actually a
way of holding that regime together
and that if expansion was prevented
if it was contained
then the regime induced course would
turn in on itself and collapse
this doctrine came to be known as
containment because it was a way of
fighting the soviet regime by containing
it rather than by defeating it at any
rate a sustained confrontation between
the two
remaining superpowers in the world
that would come to be called the cold
war
the cold war turned hot in 1950 on the
korean peninsula
which had been divided since the end of
the war between communist forces in the
north that were aligned with the soviet
union and democratic forces in the south
that were aligned with the united states
this led to an invasion on june 25th
1950 of some 80 000 north korean troops
that swept into the south very nearly
conquering it
and the truman
invoked the united nations
and the american response was funneled
through the united nations so it was
called a police action rather than
a war
there was no declaration of war the war
went very badly until uh
general douglas macarthur got involved
uh
performed a brilliant amphibious
invasion at incheon which cut off the
north korean troops and
led him quickly to be able to round them
up defeat them and then head north
and he kept going north and finally
approached the chinese border and at
that point a quarter of a million
chinese troop
swept in on macarthur and drove him back
to
into south korea with the battle line
finally stabilizing around the 38th
parallel
at this point
macarthur and truman got deadlocked in a
conflict
because
macarthur thought
the time was right the justification was
there for what he called a whole new war
a war against china against communist
china that would
succeed in overthrowing this unfriendly
hostile noxious communist regime
that had just taken power
and thus
avert
the prospect of
a sino-soviet chinese and soviet
alliance that could come to dominate the
world the time was right to take that on
truman on the other hand
thought this was absolutely the wrong
thing that it would be he called it a
booby trap to uh go into a war in china
and rejected the idea macarthur
criticized truman publicly
in an official letter to the house
minority leader
said there is no substitute for victory
in other words a rejection of the
containment doctrine there is no
predefining the fact though that the
korean war was at best a stalemate it
remains a people divided to this day
uh there is no settlement of the war uh
the war is simply suspended so in some
ways it
illustrates some of the
unsatisfactory aspects of the
containment doctrine and that situation
is yet to be resolved
thank you for watching
we hope you're enjoying our highlight
series and invite you to explore all of
hillsdale college's online courses they
are free and for everyone who loves to
learn